queda medio país de manzana quieres
comer el doble de lo que tu hermano coma
pero también tienen que guardar una
rebanada para mamá cortas una rebanada
para ella de 30 grados cuál es la medida
de tu rebanada en grados bueno vamos a
necesitar recordar algunas cosas para
resolver este problema la primera es que
si tenemos una circunferencia un un
círculo y damos toda la vuelta y damos
la vuelta completa entonces eso tiene
360 grados 360 grados vale pero aquí
nada más tenemos medio país de este modo
cuando demos la vuelta sólo vamos a
recorrer 180 grados vale entonces vamos
a recorrer nada más algo de este estilo
que son 180 grados
vamos a utilizar eso para ver cómo queda
la repartición déjame definir algunas
variables de este lado le voy a poner
que x es la medida en grados es la
medida en grados
en grados
de la rebanada de la rebanada
de mi hermano del hermano vale de el
hermano
bueno si x es la medida en grados de la
rebanada de mi hermano del hermano
entonces 2x va a ser la medida la medida
de mi rebanada de mi rebanada le va nada
la medida en grados vale
2x va a ser la medida de mi rebanada
porque yo quiero comer el doble de lo
que come mi hermano y finalmente 30
grados va a ser lo que come lo que come
mamá entonces en total este x con este 2
x x con este 2x
en estos 30 grados que guardamos en la
rebanada para mamá más 30 grados en
total debe dar 180 grados lo voy a poner
en color verde 180 grados déjame hacer
por aquí un diagrama básicamente lo que
estoy diciendo es que tenemos medio
círculo a ver si no me queda muy chueco
bueno así está suficientemente bien 30
grados son para mamá 30 grados es más o
menos esto
a 30 grados son para mamá x es para el
hermano para mi hermano lo voy a poner
en color naranja algo así y el doble de
x es para mí 2 x vale bueno vamos a
resolver esta ecuación para determinar
el valor de x
si tenemos xy le sumamos 2x se convierte
en 3x luego tenemos que sumar 30 sumar
30 y eso de ahí es igual a 180 grados es
igual a 180 grados ahora podemos restar
30 grados de ambos lados déjame tomar el
color amarillo para hacer esto resto 30
grados resto 30 grados también por acá
aquí se cancelan de este lado quedan 150
grados 150 grados y esos 150 grados son
iguales a 3 x
es x y ahora puedo dividir entre 3 de
ambos lados entre 3 y entre 3 aquí esto
se cancela y me queda que x x es igual a
150 entre 3 es decir 50 50 grados muy
bien este de aquí es el valor de x pero
nosotros no queríamos el valor de x
queríamos la medida de mi rebanada es
decir queremos 2 veces x 2 veces x es
igual a 100 entonces la respuesta sería
100 100 grados y el diagrama nos
quedaría así aquí quedaría otra vez el
semicírculo ahora si queda un poco más
feo lo voy a hacer más bonito y algo de
este estilo algo de este estilo por aquí
están los 30 grados los 30 grados que
serían para para mamá 30 grados de este
lado tenemos 50 grados que son para para
mi hermano 50 grados y aquí serían 100
grados y todos estos forman los 180
grados
semicírculo